bonjour merci d'être avec nous messieurs
alexandre langois première question vous
avez pensez quoi de cette conférence de
presse du procureur antiterroriste
déjà c'est bien de faire un point que
les gens soient informés des
informations diverses et variées donc là
ça permet de recentrer le débat d'avoir
une clarification sur des listes ou pas
et que ce soit les pouvoirs publics qui
reprennent la parole sur ce sujet plutôt
que la presse qui l'emmène dans divers
direction pierre connaissent un ex haut
fonctionnaire au ministère de la défense
est ce que cette conférence de presse a
été assez claire à ce que actuellement
l'on sait un peu plus sur l'avancée de
l'enquêté sur le meurtre de samuel pâtit
on en sait un peu plus c'est évident et
devant le rôle du procureur n'est pas de
se lancer des scoop c'est de donner ce
qui est effectivement avéré par les
premières étapes de l'enquète moi ce qui
me frappe dans ce cas dit le procureur
sait qu'il a décrit le rôle de
différents intervenants qui ont
participé selon des modalités que chacun
va considérer comme effectivement tout à
fait anodine parce que personne ne
pensait à l'horreur de la situation
finale mais en fait le seul ce processus
montre beaucoup de gens se sont associés
à cet acte criminel et donc j'espère que
on va avoir au bout du compte un
règlement de justice qui sera rapide et
présever maintenant dans ce cas des
progrès ya une chose qui m'a étonné
c'est que la fille du parent d'élève
n'est pas parmi les personnes mises en
examen
or c'est elle qui a menti dès le départ
et c'est elle qui a contribué si vous
voulez à cet état des lieux oria deux
autres mineurs dans les personnes qui
restent en détention donc je sais pas
j'ai un point qui reste ambigu pour moi
alors monsieur langlois
après ce meurtre un branle bas de combat
au niveau de l'exécutif qui veut
renforcer la lutte contre l'islamisme
radical
on a également parlé du renforcement de
la sécurité aux abords des
établissements scolaires concrètement ça
voudrait dire quoi un déploiement de
policiers autour des écoles primaires
des collèges et des lycées en france
malheureusement il faut de plus on est
dans la précipitation plutôt que dans
l'analyse c'est que dès qu'un fait
divers grave qu'il a un attentat le
les différents pouvoirs publics essaye
de mettre en place des mesures pour
rassurer l'opinion publique
donc là on va devoir surveiller des
écoles ça va durer un temps mais ce
n'est pas le problème deux fois en fait
le problème de fond c'est qu'on puisse
faire le travail au niveau du
renseignement pour éviter justement
avoir surveillé des écoles parce qu'on
aura surveiller des bonnes personnes en
amont pour les empêcher d'agir
donc on est en train de s'occuper des
conséquences final plutôt de s'attaquer
aux causes du problème alors vous
parlais justement des renseignements il
ya eu des fiches et s perquisitionné
dans cette affaire samuel pâtit le
fichage est c'est un peu leur gestion
sympa en danger de sociétés dans cette
lutte contre le terrorisme mais c'est un
peu flou est ce que je le rappelle le
fichage est ce n'est pas une preuve de
culpabilité
monsieur kone sage et vous poser cette
question
concrètement on en fait quoi des fiches
et s on les surveille de très près côté
c'est pas moi qu'il faudrait poser la
question à c'est plutôt monsieur parce
que c'est pas mon travail et moi moi ce
qui me frappe si vous voulez dans cette
affaire encore une fois c'est que ce
fameux imams autoproclamés qui
effectivement va mener la procédure de
bout en bout puisqu'il s'associe très
vite à la plaine dieu du parent d'élève
celui là avait un dossier extrêmement
lourd il est efficace mais il avait
participé à différentes actions
illégales et en particulier la plus
étonnante et l'attaquent qu'il avait
mené avec d'autres spire de son
organisation contre la mosquée de l'imam
chalghoumi parce qu'il le considère
comme un musulman traître alors moi je
me pose la question c'est à dire est-ce
qu'il fallait pas s'apercevoir un peu
plus tôt que monsieur avait un dossier
justiciables d'une explique d'une
expulsion
moi j'aurais tendance à penser que oui
de même que je suis a toujours un peu
étonné que notre newsletter découvre de
134 dossiers qui peuvent de vol
aujourd'hui faire l'objet de procédures
d'expulsion sur wes qu'ils étaient ces
dossiers était dans son bureau j'étais
couvert de poussière ans fraîchement
monsieur non justement est-ce que vos
niveaux de la police vous avez des
directives pour les fiches s les fiches
est donc il faut savoir c'est que si
jamais c'était c'est des soupçons de
tags de terroristes pour la réalisation
par exemple il ya différents types de
fichiers il n'y a pas que celle-là
et après c'est où nous avons des
soupçons donc nous sommes en train
d'essayer de les étayer pour pouvoir s'y
[ __ ] et à plus de soupe sion mais qu'ils
sont avérées pour le coup c'est qu'il ya
des faits c'est pour les présenter à la
justice et du coup nous ne sommes plus
dans du renseignement mais on passe dans
du service judiciaire
justement empêcher ces gens nuire les
arrêter que la justice fasse son travail
effectivement on suit les fiches est ya
différents niveaux de fish est également
donc en fait on nous parle de
fourre-tout dandy fichier s oui mais
après les richesses qui sont fichiers
eux mêmes parce qu'ils sont dangereux il
est fiché s qui sont en lien avec des
personnes dangereuses si ça nous
intéresse de faire leur environnement
pour savoir qui on peut avoir comme
information donc c'est un enjeu est un
outil très important pour le travail des
services de renseignement et bien
évidemment si jamais ce n'est plus du
renseignement mais que les faits sont
trouvés on les envoie devant la justice
et en tant que policier de la menace
islamiste terroriste
est ce que vous êtes formés pour y faire
face il ya différents acteurs on est
formés en fonction de nos services et de
nos unités on a des collègues ont été
formés sur le terrain je pense par
exemple au bac à être primo intervenants
en cas d'attentât nous nous sommes
formés à la radicalisation à la
détection de ces faisceaux d'indicés au
niveau du renseignement pour essayer de
faire les choses mais par exemple les
services de renseignement français sont
très compliquées dans leur organisation
est ce que c'est très bureaucratique
c'est ce qu'on a pu constater par
exemple sur cette affaire à conflans
sainte honorine c'est qu'il ya un
problème structurel dans les services de
renseignement français c'est qu'il ya
une académie du renseignement en france
mais de deux des services qui étaient
dans la boucle par exemple
renseignements territoriale et la
direction du renseignement de la
préfecture de police ne font pas partie
de l'académie du renseignement
donc chacun est cloisonné dans son coin
un essai c'était aussi lourdeurs
administratives qui empêchent de lutter
efficacement et avec notre syndicat on
n'arrête pas de répéter qu'ils avaient à
l'époque les renseignements généraux qui
ont été dissous en 2008 qui avait des
fois effectivement certaines failles au
niveau de la sécurité des informations
mais qui avait par contre une rapidité
de réaction qui est nécessaire dans un
monde qui va aussi vite avec les réseaux
sociaux les téléphones etc
alors il ya des terroristes qui ont agi
sur le sol français qui ont fait
allégeance à des groupes djihadistes
actifs dans des pays étrangers citons
par exemple
esch la lutte contre l'islam radical en
france ne passe-t-elle pas aussi par la
lutte contre le terrorisme en général
monsieur conesa s'éteint c'est une
question très très général mais vous
savez toutes les cartes ont été
brouillées au moment où george bush
cessons ces grands son grand discours
sur le la guerre globale contre le
terrorisme et le département d'état
américain publié une liste je crois de
143 groupe terroriste sur la planète
dans laquelle ils mélangent
effectivement des mouvements quand il
sera et il ya des irlandais enfin vous
dire c'est un espèce de fourre tout
parce qu'il fallait que george bush
sorte de la difficulté qu'avait été
l'extraordinaire échec des attentats du
11 septembre nous et nous n'étions pas
obligés de 2,7 à adhérer si vous voulez
à cette conception générale la guerre
globale contre le terrorisme est ce
qu'on voit une fois en rappelez vous qui
avez case saudia sur 19 terroristes dans
les attentats du 11 septembre
personne ne m'a désigné l'arabie saudite
surtout pas changer bouge donc on est
dans une guerre qui a été brouillée par
un discours diplomatique
nous n'avons pas nous à nous préoccuper
que de certaines formes de carrosserie
qui ne sont pas directement ciblée sur
nous vous avez aujourd'hui si vous
voulez des hindouistes radicaux qui vont
faire des attentats contre des musulmans
band c'est pas notre objet par contre
effectivement identifié les pays qui ont
contribué à la propagation du salafisme
en france où des frères musulmans en
france oui ça c'est en prenant un enjeu
majeur et donc dans ce ce moyen là je
reviens sur ce que disait monsieur tout
à l'heure aux faut pas faire de la garde
statique c'est à dire qu'on va pas
mettre un policier dans chaques lycée et
à 30 mille communes en france on va pas
disperser les forces non il faut que le
l'offensive se fasse à l'intérieur de
ces réseaux sociaux rappelez vous quand
même que quand on avait eu la ferme il a
cette jeune fille avait été l'objet de
30 mille tweets menaçant bon on voit
bien que c'est une technique
d'agressions de mise en tension qui fait
que nos services de police n'ont pas les
moyens d'identifier chacun de ces twitts
dans la ferme il a il ya eu trois
condamnations en plus ce qui était
essentiellement des enfants qui étaient
du collège de la jeune fille là on est
en provenance exactement sur le même
problème et on a après l'assassinât
encore des tweets de soutien si vous
voulez l'acte terroriste
donc il ya une méthode qu'il faut il
doit changer
la pression sur les grands opérateurs du
net malheureusement on voit que ça a été
donnée ça n'a pas donné tous les
résultats escomptés
et donc il faut changer la méthode est
attaqué le salafisme dans ses bases
comme ça commence à lui seul faire mais
je suis encore toujours amer de
regretter qu'il ya beaucoup de choses
n'ont pas été faites avant la reconnais
sa merci d'avoir été avec moi je
rappelle que vous êtes ex haut
fonctionnaire au ministère de la défense
alexandre langlois merci à vous
également êtes syndicat policier
vj merci à tous les deux d'avoir été en
direct avec nous sur rt francs